who who started World War II
men men
who finished World War II Men okay we
are the most useful deadly force on this
planet who enforces feminism man
that's the only way you can enforce it
yes it's go you go yeah man
this is the first time
something masculine and we're shamed for
it being oh
why don't you think they celebrate
masculinity because it's a threat it's a
threat listen who who started World War
II
who finished World War II Men okay we
are the most useful deadly force on this
planet and they're just trying to
monopolize manhood when you look at look
at the government all this [__] they
say about like you know violence is not
the answer and don't do this and
violence is never the way um who has a
monopoly on violence in society if you
don't pay your taxes they'll they'll
drag you and lock you in a cell if you
don't follow the laws they'll [__]
kill you yeah you know so men men are
the ones men are and probably talk about
studies all the time that you do right
men are the ones that are the most
disagreeable in society oh yeah you know
what I mean men are the ones that always
push back and men are the ones who
consistently lead revolutions like yeah
please name one female-led revolution
I think it's a feminism probably that's
not a revolution
feminism was funded by the CIA too it
was funded by the CIA
who enforces feminism man that's the
only way you can enforce it yes it's go
you go yeah man this is the first time
you did something masculine and we're
shamed for it
either like a woman or like Society like
you noticed like wow I can't I can't do
this or maybe a girl shamed you like
what was the first time you can give a
perspective and be shamed okay somebody
sucker punched my friend in a pizza
joint in Orlando after we were drinking
and uh I whooped that guy's ass and I
whooped his friend's ass and then
there's a girlfriend of mine which is
just like you shouldn't have done that
I'm like my friend got punched in the
face like I'm not a [__] [__] I
gotta defend my friend's honor wow
sometimes I get set up to have to be the
bad guy like like it could be a thing of
if I go for this way of doing it or the
complete opposite of way doing it I
still like look at that guy regardless
yeah I think that that's just like I
think the reason why that gets put on us
a lot more is because because we're seen
as the top heads of things it's easy to
put more responsibility on us but I
think to some degree people misbalance
it yeah and then they can end up like
putting an unrealistic expectation
yeah and like what's happening with this
role of tomasi says this often and it's
pretty true when he says right now
they're trying to push responsibility on
men while stripping them of authority
that responsibility and Authority needs
to come hand in hand because you know
like if you get reprimanded at your boss
I reprimanded work by your boss right
yeah but your boss can't fire you'll be
like yo [__] you bro I'm not gonna do
whatever you're gonna tell me what to do
but the fact that he has the authority
yeah to demote you or or transfer you to
[__] Uganda or whatever and ruin your
situation with your income or your
livelihood his authority is also
directly tied to responsibility and
that's why it's hilarious too when I go
to the states when I go fresh to fit and
I talk to all these psychotic American
feminist women and they're just like no
matter what it reminds me of the episode
of of uh Fresh Prince of Bel Air when
will was in trouble and they're like
that this fan family's motto when in
doubt blame will it's like an American
women when in doubt display men yeah
like when have you ever heard when have
you ever heard an American woman or a
woman in general be like you know what
things didn't work out me and my ex but
let me first tell you things that I did
wrong
after an engagement she said all the
things that she did wrong and it made
the news
women said she she was the problem in a
relationship front page of the New York
Times woman takes accountability wow
like response I think Andrew Tate said
this responsibility with that Authority
is slavery is um yeah it is slavery and
that's what they want well you just said
before about a woman and taking
accountability and stuff I literally
just to the accountability stage the
other day
you know what 26 years
my life here and I just said to myself
my love life didn't work out and I don't
think it's because of men I think it's
because of me I have good guys bad guys
in between but I get entertained by the
ones that are more difficult scenario
like it's just like we're playing mind
games on and off all this toxicity a lot
of bad boys
but it's like I've definitely
entertained people that had red flags
written all over them well for no reason
do you okay so do you it's interesting
when girls when we take accountability
I can't say this it's always I choose
toxic men not the toxic behaviors that
we play
um
accountability if you're just saying I'm
entertaining the toxic men because no
I'll be like
it takes two to tango yeah I've been in
a toxic relationship before and I was
toxic yeah absolutely you can't you
can't be with someone for more than
maybe through a month or two three
months tops yeah without being toxic
together
and blaming it on them and saying they
just made me toxic no like toxic people
don't do toxic but you know what it's
even more subtle than that isn't it
because it's kind of like it's a it's a
half sort of admitting it's a
half-taking accountability like uh yeah
you know I I kind of entertain the wrong
guys but then it's just because they're
toxic she is also early in the stage
though she's awesome
I've got it and been with was um I was
18 and he was 28. so he already had a
one-up on me because he okay so we're
gonna test this right now I'm gonna test
this right now your past relationship
that ended what was wrong what was one
thing you did that you could have done
differently to make it a better
relationship
not chosen a toxic guy
and then after that we're gonna put your
Instagram on this on the main screen
[Laughter]
I've learned a lot but um the red flags
I could have definitely paid attention
okay this idea that we're so naive and
stupid at 18 when all right come on I
know but the thing is I definitely
thought like I was naive a bit because I
what happened like what what ended the
relationship it was on and off because
instead of him communicating with me he
would punish me with silent treatment
and blocking and then my emotions would
be up and down okay what what did you do
to have him block you
um okay I'll give you an example I went
on a girls trip okay okay pause pause
pause
with one girl yeah and I basically saw
him the day before and I told him
communicated everything to him and the
day before the day before I'm flying out
he didn't even give him more notice like
oh yeah okay wait so okay so you're
seeing a girl this is cooking up you
know so so wait did you did you ask him
if you could go on the girls trip yes
yeah and he said yes yes and he said yes
okay so I now went I said with one girl
I spoke to him before for that and
everything was fine I went over there he
um hacked my phone I found out when I
got back he hacked my phone okay
um but when I got there I was sending
him snaps like I'm looking cute look at
me look at this look at that he was
giving me off Behavior he was being a
bit standoffish out of nowhere he
decided to block me and I'm like oh my
God my feelings are hurt
usually when girls tell this story it
sounds like there's more to the story is
that it doesn't seem like he would just
block you I don't know
men don't just leave girls you know like
you see when it comes to like um like
obviously I'm not saying that oh I you
know how your situation went in it but
I'm saying in general yeah when it comes
to like relationships a man will
normally leave or block a girl when his
head is absolute limit with her like
even it because a guy okay cool let's
say that you catch a guy cheating yeah
and he's like oh he pissed me every kid
like he's not gonna be like okay let's
just block each other to to fix however
yeah like nine times out of ten he's
gonna by the way you know whatever fit
you got him because you know like so
then it's like in the snow you know when
you say that oh boom like he just
blocked me like I I know what it's like
to be a guy in it like you know what
it's like to be a guy and you know it's
like do you know what it's like to be an
emotional guy though because I feel like
this guy was very emotional okay
this is the thing like this is the thing
I've been I've been with a guy that's
emotional right and I've been in that
like I've been in a toxic relationship
like I'm not that same maybe he was a
hacking my phone but like but like you
have to you have to but like you cannot
like until you get through your head
that you cannot be in a toxic
relationship without being toxic you'll
never learn and you'll never grow
because there's no way that he you're
just the victim he just hacked your
phone like there's things that you did
that were probably drama-filled probably
attention seeking there there was
something you did and like like if
you're a healthy individual I know what
I did oh I know why it's his brother's
dick
don't do that I don't like those phrases
anyway
um yeah I'm respectful Muslim women
please wait wait
tell me how did he hack your phone can
we talk about this for a second yeah
what is hacking was he was he tracking
you on iCloud oh no basically I don't I
don't think I should share this
information with people because maybe it
was just is it was it an app no
basically there's a thing where you have
an iPhone or an Android he can do
something to my phone put his number in
then he will
he's done that and I think what I've
done is
um I was just always looking good
posting my Snaps looking cute and I
think that was triggering him
so let me let me just say like this is
this is why this translates to guys you
were acting like a hoe yeah no no no no
there's no skin out it's just face
my head
it's still advertising this is how men
see it yes you might not like it and you
know a lot of us have never been taught
this stuff okay but because we've never
heard what men think but so you to men
this is you're acting like a hoe and
then you get blocked yeah
listen as well at the same time hold on
wait wait listen and this is the thing
like like we can't move forward in life
unless we could see where we went wrong
in certain situations and I'll tell you
this from like personal experience like
there's times been listening to a guy on
the show and I'll think wow I like did
like this is where I went wrong like
I've apologized to people before you
know I'm always open-minded to learn I
never looked at it from that aspect the
way I see it's like from when my boobs
and everything is not out on this screen
yeah and you can just see my face and my
you said you said he's an emotional guy
but you said that you you told him the
day before you were going on the girls
trip right yeah so where was the girls
trip so Portugal I want more information
I want more information
is it okay what's your Instagram right
now let me look at it this I'm just
honey
wait can we put it on the screen I wanna
I wanna react to him
hold on hold on guys I am on a journey
of like becoming more religious so I am
going to Rebrand my Instagram
[Laughter]
this Instagram is absolutely Haram
and then your honor the evidence I'd
like to present to the court is uh
picture number five from the top and
picture number one
pretty pretty Haram do you want to
please please
I don't this is this is was this the
type of stuff you were you were posting
uh look at that picture in the middle
that's Haram right there oh why are you
showing your backside to the world yeah
that's the ass Nikki store
you know I think it is yeah Instagram
guys that's that's not crazy
it's still to some degree okay look it's
her room as in as in like okay you can
see a bit of legs you can see a bit of
hair but however even with that most
people would have been like oh my God
this is not even nothing but we're in
the westernized society
I'm just gonna do you see how your gut
reaction isn't to listen it's to defend
yourself yeah yeah like I know I know I
do that
like oh maybe it is a bit haramic
wait wait you're still waiting turn off
for Mike
yeah but it's like it's like if that's
your initial response it's probably
contributed something because like if
you think your exes could have told you
something
yeah but see this is this is what women
do too so you're still now you're saying
well it's how I grew up and so now it's
like it's not on you it's on someone
else
I've done this stuff before too it's
okay but it's something that I can
change but as far as let's go back to my
Instagram goes I battled this with
myself as well so I'm like okay I do
um I used to have way more pictures no
archived and everything and I'm
literally like slowly finding a way to
you know become more more distressed I
think it's a perspective thing you know
and it's not a bad idea
and that's I'm not saying that's not a
bad thing that's good yeah but I'm just
saying when we look back at situations
if we're always blame like pointing the
finger we can't grow can't get better
yeah listen let's ask the chat Chad if
you think her Instagram is Haram Pusha
one
push it two right there well I'm Haram
right now for not wearing a headscarf so
let's start then
we're in a Christian Nation
but you know what I think it is though I
generally think here that the issue here
isn't necessarily intentional or
malicious I think it's just a
perspective thing in this generation I
don't feel like a lot of women learn how
men are like or how they think or like
what their desires are so so it's like
the way it can translate across is that
oh wait I see that men like big boobs so
that was clearly what they want us but
if females actually sit down with men
and say what would you want from a wife
now you know from your Instagram
um early on you can 100 argue it's not
that deep you know you can argue on one
side of the coin but on the flip side of
the coin you can also argue where the
action she's faced away from the screen
we've got a bottom to the screen yeah
the intention let's say that you don't
it doesn't matter what she's wearing
let's say the intention alone how could
people perceive it could we perceive it
as that's a woman that's got a husband
and that's a woman that you know is in a
relationship or could we perceive it as
oh she's single like dude I'm saying
um three years ago I would have never
get back with him oh this is three years
ago yeah but he he would always come
back I thought you said oh he'd always
come back wait wait I thought you said
he was eight you were 18 he was 28. but
so how aren't you 26 yeah so then you
would have been 23 is this a different X
yeah so it's okay yeah okay so I've been
with him for like four years
so so when you were you were 22 you got
with him for four years no 18 I go with
him no no the last text how long were
you with him Portugal X
this was the main serious relationship I
would consider in my life the rest was
like getting to know you okay okay
how old were you when you met him how
old were you when you met him when did
you break up 18 we had an on and off
relationship up until 22 23 I would say
Okay okay so 2018 to 22. yeah that'd
answer your question no
wait so eight 18 to 20s you dated him
for four years on and off so on and off
that means the relationship was [__] but
the sex was good
no we've never had sex
actually I'm a blank right now four
years of this wow that's you I don't are
you a virgin
yes
do we have a stop yeah
hold on
you don't what what I don't know okay no
this is best we shouldn't even have this
discussion no no no no no nothing about
me right now to be fair it's for me yeah
I'm just learning it because this is a
completely different Insight because you
because you're coming with a Muslim
background yeah and you got these types
of insights behind you yeah this sounds
pretty different to me like for example
you've been saying like you're 26 right
now you're a virgin we're in a western
Society I haven't heard that since I was
like 15 that's something a virgin this
so that's some reason why like we're
asking and it's like
this is the thing as well they're
surprised because you don't portray
yourself like a virgin which is which is
a which is a great you know based on
that you're born are you important I'm
not saying I'm not saying it's like a
well is she a born-again version they
don't believe you but I'm saying there's
a reason they think you're capable yeah
I think you're capping no okay
I'm cupping for my Instagram but no one
has virgin on it no but I'm saying no
yeah but usually like I've had virgin
girls come on the show where nobody
really nobody really like wait wait
nobody really like pushes back right but
it's not like it's just it's a good
thing right that's like a great thing I
think that's awesome it is good but it's
like it's like unfortunate because I'm
like No One Believes you because of the
Instagram
it's like it's like it loses but yeah
that's a great thing nobody has that no
that's why I want to change my Instagram
too
I'm gonna go home and archive that
picture okay
I'm just gonna give you the charge right
now honey do you remember the
conversation we had before the cameras
were on
what do you mean what conversation about
the situation you told me about I don't
remember we was just talking in general
no but do you remember about the
situation you told me about that I was
giving you advice on
it was a general situation I can't
remember exactly where the word folk
what does that have to do with this part
because you just told everyone here
something that from that situation I was
that what were you talking about because
I wasn't talking about me and myself in
that situation you you were I don't let
out you because I know the camera maybe
you don't want to you don't want people
to know what you're talking about
honestly I was talking about situation
with my friend just in general but I
don't know I just met you do I know you
look don't be rude to me yeah because
I'm not trying to be don't be rude to me
but I'm just I'm just trying to say some
sort of no I haven't I haven't hold on
I've not said anything about anything
yeah I'm just saying do you remember the
conversation that we had I remember some
of the conversations we had yeah most of
them yeah this is like a politician
isn't it yeah
this conversation this was about an hour
ago so you you remember all of it then
don't you yeah okay you know you're
saying I remember I remember the
conversation you remember I was talking
about a lot of things yeah okay but no
but we specifically were talking about a
situation that I was giving you advice
on we were talking about for about 45
minutes right I was talking about about
a certainly my situation that was your
situation no it wasn't
stop the cab
[Laughter]
um
you're literally saying this Captain you
don't know me
can I say this though
fake teeth okay wait before they're not
necessary but listen what can I say this
though can I say this
hey you're not gonna insult him
okay that's right but he's saying I'm
capping
look wait wait myself read the label
look it's Laurel piano you don't have to
get to fancy you don't know it's about
me and myself and my buddy if you're
just gonna argue can I say this then are
you making a joke about the fresh and
pit podcast when they push the button it
goes beep stop the cap that is actually
a thing on the person thing is trying to
trigger me I apologize if that was the
case but you could come check the label
on my suit it's it costs more than your
outfit
hey guys guys guys guys let me just see
okay before a a woman that's okay okay
cool well let me say this you know the
reason why I thought they couldn't speak
a bit of tension right now and a bit of
disagreement is only because earlier
when you were speaking about the city
um girl situation or the um the holiday
thing that happened I remember at one
point you did also say oh and then that
happened and it's not me saying that
you're a liar or anything like that it's
just that within this limited time of
knowing you yeah if I if someone says a
story then misses out a story I can only
go off my imagination and it doesn't
necessarily mean that I'm tying you or
saying yo straight home straight this
did it it's not that but you have to
remember all of us not all of us but
we're all a lot of us are just meeting
each other for the first time and we're
going off of you see first impressions
are the most important because they're
the ones that stick the longest so
obviously in regards to the Instagram
it's not even like I've looked at
Instagram and said yo you're dressed mad
it's not even that it's just that when
you say I'm a virgin and then there's
quite a few westernized similarities
like it just in common and similarities
like do you see how someone that's a
stranger could be like oh maybe I don't
I don't understand no if she's a virgin
not black yeah that's fine but that's
you lost opinion yeah yeah that's fine
everyone could have different opinions
yeah yeah you can't insult my guest I
apologize for him because I thought he
was coming for me and to calling me a
liar that's why okay
okay I'm not here to disrespect anyone
but I just felt a bit attacked so I was
defending myself he wasn't he wasn't
attacking you I just because when he
kept saying felt but it's like you keep
having this like visceral reaction you
can stay because you apologized okay if
you want to you can say but but you
can't you can't you can't insult my gas
like that's it's not but you would you
were deflecting as well because it
seemed like there was some opposing
evidence to what you're saying no it
wasn't it was just everyone just putting
their little two cents in and um it
wasn't you guys don't know it was a fact
as well so it was just a bit like I'm
saying what I'm saying you know she just
respect what I'm saying whether you
believe it or not and just call it a day
to some degree though like it's it's
like to something I accept that that's
fair it's just that to some degree
though it is a it's a public podcast
that wall just putting opinions forward
in it like it's normal that someone can
put an opinion for you and if I think yo
boom I don't really agree with that or I
don't I could be wrong you know but it's
it's for you to be able to be like you
know what yeah you may not be agreeing
with me but this is a podcast isn't it
but it's like but people are just gonna
have something to say against what you
got to say of course that's that's why
I'm on social media I already know that
people are gonna say they stand out
about me so it's okay it's cool where's
my best actor because I need to hand it
over real quick
I'm gonna ask him questions and I'll ask
you questions so so this conversation
this conversation
[Laughter]
so so this conversation you don't have
to tell me what she said but it's
basically contradicting what she's
saying now
[Music]
um
there are some things that she has said
on this podcast right that does not
align with things she that we discussed
but it's her life I will not disclose
anything that she said because we were
discussion I was hoping through a
situation so I wouldn't disclose
anything because if she doesn't want it
to be public that's fine but that's why
I was asking her do you remember the
conversation because it doesn't some
things are not aligning you know this
happens
okay I've warned you I told you I told
you I'm going to ask you questions in a
second okay cool no I need you this is
I've warned you you gotta go all right
that's fine I'll just go because this is
just feeling a bit like too much of an
attack okay okay
um
okay okay that's fine just go that's why
oh Troy I'll come sit next to you please
I need a hug now
that's what they're saying they're like
why'd you bring it up it's like what did
she think okay uh we're gonna get it
today no you don't you know what's funny
though
okay do you know what's funny though
this happens to me all the time on the
show this happens to me all the time
where like someone will say something
but I don't want to say anything yeah I
can yeah yeah I I saw it in real time no
no and it's like yeah so I I know what
you mean I think ultimately no go ahead
ultimately
like [__] it it's just that I think some
people can just be new in it oh mine no
no that one like this
but yeah if you're coming on the park
because you should know what you're
saying look listen like Everyone's
entitled to the Privacy Etc that but I'm
a bit like oh boy if you've said
something I don't know like if you said
something that I'm like I was just
that's why I said look I'm just saying
do you remember the conversation does
the truth trigger people
or do lies trigger people like what
which one is it what Society are we
talking about this one the British one
depends on the truth
well I mean it's a little bit
disingenuous if you're going to come on
to a show and say something that's I
mean
that you you're directly contradicting
something that you've revealed to
somebody else yeah just prior to that
show
particularly particularly if it's
something that you're trying to cast
yourself in a good life
yeah I think that's something I
understand because I'm like nobody
expected her to be a virgin you know
what I mean like yeah I didn't say
that's what it was just for the record I
didn't say that's what it was that was
she was what a version
that's what she was saying yeah
now once you lay it out this is you just
accept what comes with it and so I was
projecting and maybe Troy gentlemen you
guys could agree with me or not I have
been in on and off relationships with
girls and the only thing that was
keeping us both there was really good
sex like yeah
Mr Rickett do you agree with me you're
the dating coach or no you disagree like
if it's on and off it's like you're
having sex but it's not a commitment but
that was not it
okay so then and I'm open to
understanding the truth so like what
we're on and off was why did I stay what
was the on and off about and was it the
sex mediocre or
um
it was all right it wasn't great so what
is the context of the off and on like
what happened
um
it was just like maybe I'd like go
through his phone and find something I
didn't like you know I was kind of I was
kind of looking for problems if I'm
being honest yeah and I really would
overreact about a lot of stuff what did
you find when you went through his phone
um I don't wanna
um you know like messages that sort of
thing but two other girls
partially but I I think I kind of
overreacted on a lot of them like it
wasn't really that deep were you
overreacting because you wanted to find
a reason to overreact or was it just
because you were triggered emotionally
um
interesting yeah it's interesting
because I was thinking why is it so many
girls will go through guys photos and
it's insecurity right yeah I've I've had
girls I had a girlfriend like every
single girl that I've ever dated really
used to would go through my phone and
there was one girl I was dating and she
would like literally every time she came
round she'd go oh yeah I've seen
something on your phone you know it's
very it's very like it's addicting you
got to get your next fix and that's what
I that's what I realized I was like I
keep like like if I like I obviously
don't care because I keep we keep
getting back together and I keep looking
for problems yeah is she still here or
is she like no I think she laughed it's
King was she taken out okay
um what did she say bro tell us
your favorite listen I'm sorry listen
listen that I don't think she's a virgin
I think she knows people that are going
to see her on social media and she's
gonna get shamed for being a shitty
Muslim I I have never met you someone
such with such a visceral reaction
like virgins don't know how to be that
toxic
that comes from trauma I've had virgin
like girls come on the show and yeah
they're Meek they're like yeah
yeah yeah yeah they're very Meek you
know you can you tell
um
consistent for me like I see too many
times that she say something then
someone else will say something to be
like oh I just remember this happened to
you okay
this isn't anything crazy but she was
she was like telling me a story about
like a guy or whatever that she had
history with and then she was saying
about how like her sister he then I
think she called it off so then he went
for her sister right and I was like oh
wow that's like kind of mad that's
really weird and I was like you know I
had that happen I was like oh this
happened she was like you know my sister
got his number I was like wait your your
sister got his number
she was like yeah I was like how did she
get his number so oh well I gave her
gave it to her I was like wait I'm
confused so did he go after your sister
or did your sister go after him
because she was like he was like oh well
you know a pet she was like oh well he
said no because her sister said no
because you know he had already been
with her
and I was like wait but you gave your
sister her number his number right and
then did she reach out to him she was
like okay yeah so she reached out yeah
okay
it wasn't like he he called it off with
him then he went after your sister like
you ended things right she was
interested you gave her the number and
green lit the situation and then you
didn't like it after and I was a bit
like after asking these questions I was
like she painted it kind of one way yeah
when I actually found out I was like
yeah yeah yeah it was completely yeah
did you see how I decided to sit my tea
at one point I decided to I'm just
listening you know
more believable if she wasn't like the
fact that she got so mad because if
someone said something about you that's
like how did my teeth come into the
conversation
you might find it annoying right so you
might be like okay like what up but if
you're getting like angry at insulting
people I'm just like well like yeah but
you know from what she described earlier
I wouldn't be surprised if she said if
I'm a childhood of arguing my brothers
I'd have to lie every now and again if
I'm a child with arguments that I feel
like you know like I I like in general I
think once someone has that defense
that's so thick so thick there's nothing
you can like you can't actually truly
trust the story that comes out of their
mouth basically being rude isn't it just
sort of illustrate what Pearl's been
saying though about like not taking that
accountability yeah yeah yeah yeah
but there's not taking accountability
then there's lying
there's there's like in this I'm seeing
a mixture of about three types of things
in one no but then it's like it was
pretty toxic
relationship you don't get that you
don't get that toxic without getting
trauma in a relationship too
I'm sorry like you cannot it takes two
to tangle I want yeah I will not deal
with this like
narrative that oh it's only him that's
toxic toxic [__] she just got toxic
right here
when you think about it you're supposed
to listen to your man right so like
you're supposed like you're not supposed
to argue with it Paul can I ask a
question as well didn't she say that
because I don't believe that as well
early one woman she was speaking about
her boyfriend uh about oh yeah it was
three years ago then we found out it's a
whole different X now I know I caught
that too how many X's were there
she was like she was like 22. yeah she
said oh 18 I was with him for you I was
like three years and then now you're 26.
it could be it could be a thing she was
like she could they could have broken up
when she was like well she said two and
a half she said she said it like in one
line she didn't mention she didn't say
oh that was that X by the way this other
X she literally just said oh yeah and
when I was suddenly uh your experience
what does that mean when women are like
Miss whatever the ACT oh like what is
that well when they missed their ex no
no when they're like the details of the
timelines they're off like what in your
like when your experience what does that
typically mean well
okay it's very simple okay first okay
for here's a couple wrapped legs I
picked up
number one she's a woman no I'm just
joking
[Laughter]
all right based
red flag number two that I picked up was
when I asked her are you a virgin she
was like
yes
and it's not facial dude she's looking
like this is the pause and then number
three okay you don't have to sit there
and think and remember about the truth
you know the truth just comes up you're
like oh yeah it's just that that was
that right and so when she had to sit
back and like remember the truth I was
just like oh I don't know and then the
inconsistencies and the stories and then
kit with the with the KO punch was like
wait a minute because what we were
talking about after this and she was
like [__] you and your actor or more
[__]
when I met her she said my suit was nice
on the balcony didn't she like she said
something she said something about my
suit in the balcony she was like yeah
the suit was nice and then now it's
always coming into this I'm just curious
experience like what are they hiding
like what is the some sort of some sort
of treachery and deception that she
because she women are smart enough to
know
how they're perceived yeah and they're
definitely under they're definitely know
when a camera's on them or they're being
interrogated by somebody and they
there's an authority over them so she's
like oh wait oh I'm definitely a virgin
yeah and uh did you notice how as well
though she said oh we shouldn't be
talking about this because I thought you
know your second point I thought that
the reason she paused was because she
didn't she felt uncomfortable with
revealing like talking about her
sexuality like that on a public forum
but then she then said oh yes I'm a
virgin but we should be talking about
this yeah yeah
that's what they'll do they'll bring up
a situation and when you ask the
questions they don't like then they
don't want to talk about it but they
always bring it up first always but then
that leads on to like what we're talking
about with how a lot of men will leave
their actions a lot of females will
leave with their emotions I really think
that what I saw earlier on was a
gigantic emotional response and a
defense mechanism along with a lot a lot
of emotions mixed in because because
well and the girl that came on that I
actually like believe was a virgin you
know like she was good
like how could you just because I
haven't seen that episode in it so how
how was she uh no she was great she was
on um yeah yeah you believe it right
yeah was it the one who wore glasses
were a mask because she didn't want to
be upset 500 believe she's a virgin
she was really um I think she was on
fresh and fit once too
yeah she was on fresh and fit one she
went super viral on there no she was
just a sweetheart like she was just so
sweet
um she wasn't defensive at all and she
wouldn't go around like I think she was
kind of like she didn't even want to say
that she was a virgin do you know what I
mean like she wanted me to try to put it
out there like that and then what like
isn't that the ultimate Flex so like
yeah I am a virgin like why would you be
hesitant to release that information but
I mean all of us here we're obviously
we're all non-virgins right we're all
cool no you're definitely not a virgin
I decided I'm born again now you were
born of England
she got mad when I said that I was like
are you a born-again virgin she's like
don't [__] tell that [__] to me yeah
yeah I'm a proud born again
I just bought it off at eBay
I love the way your MLB suit always
comes into this though so like
all of my suits are Loro piano you know
think about it all bro like when a
woman's arguing with you they'll try to
get you where it hurts didn't I say that
earlier I said that earlier she's like
when you're when you're logically making
a point she's like yeah well that's why
you get thank you
[__] sucks
he loves it
I mean she was clearly triggered clearly
triggered and you don't get triggered by
you know like lies and [__] you get
triggered by when somebody hits the
truth if she said that her body count
was full I wouldn't care no one else
would eat no no I think I think I think
it's because and I'm not saying this is
what she was lying about but I think
it's because as a Muslim or someone who
works too yeah right Muslim and this is
a public forum right yeah yeah there is
a level of appearance and reputation
certain age people
You're Expecting even if she whatever
religion you're what you're expecting
she's a virgin yeah and then another and
I wanted to tell her too like for me
personally like if a girl has Snapchat
that's a [__] red flag
that's just a red flag like what are you
doing for me personally like you're just
on a platform that deletes all evidence
it's like are you kidding me like and
then no like come on you're on and like
you're not even a social media is she an
influencer she have a big Channel she's
doing something she didn't she didn't
say that she is I'm youtubing and trying
to get back into it and like you know
she said she's saying she's starting up
like you know she's good she's got a
platform